one of the things we talked to students
about is is countering what the left
does over and over again certainly on
campus but even in society if they
disagree with you they call you a series
of names you're you're racist you're
sexist you're transphobic whatever it is
sometimes it doesn't even matter if
that's the topic you're talking about
that's their way of intimidating people
out of real debate real discussion our
counter for those of us center right
can't be coming up with their own series
of names but I think rather pushing this
larger nerve that really is about Unity
is saying hey I don't care uh whether
you're black or white young or old rich
or poor I don't care where you're born
here you legally came here for somewhere
else I don't care about your orientation
or anything else what I care about is
that you should have the same freedoms
and the same opportunities as as I
inherited and others have inherited from
our parents and grandparents that's the
American dream that's a bigger issue
than just conservative or liberal out
there and it's the one that truly does
bring people together
foreign
are you guys worried at all that just
the entropy of all this will always drag
things left I mean even right now if you
think about it you know there's a big
movement for school choice happening on
the right so more and more parents will
select out of the main systems
personally I obviously think that's a
good thing and they'll either homeschool
or charter school or pods or whatever it
might be but at the college level that
they're either just not going to go to
college or they will just figure out
other ways to go into the workforce thus
leaving the colleges in essence to the
Socialists
yeah I think it ran both counts I mean
I've said the reaction if you're a
parent being upset about what we've seen
either taught or not taught in our
schools over the last few years
particularly during the pandemic is one
of the three things get involved run for
school board take your school board over
do something that takes your Traditional
government-run School and puts it on the
right track go to a private school if
you're in a state like Wisconsin where I
expanded school choice parental school
choice options Statewide send your kid
to a private school with a voucher or
tax credit or other things like that or
if you've got the capacity and the
ability to homeschool but you're right
in those last two options and certainly
when it comes to colleges and
universities that de facto then leaves a
whole NASA people in the government-run
institutions that don't have that don't
have a counter to all that which is
precisely why what we're doing at Young
America's Foundation is so important why
af.org if people are interested and that
is people sometimes say hey do you have
a do you have a a yaf chapter at
Hillsdale we do but I'm like I'm not
worried about Hillsdale
I'm worried about exactly I'm worried
about Stanford I'm worried about Harvard
I'm wondering about Yale you know I'm
worried about so many public
government-run institutions and so
that's why our work is certainly not
done even as people send their kids to
alternatives to the government-run
institutions we've got to fight every
single day and every single one of these
campuses to get the truth out and
remember the island is you know free
speech is something that's protected by
our constitution but it should be
revered of all places on our college
campuses yet traditionally that's where
we're at the most at risk and so we're
going to fight there we're going to
fight on campus and we get there one of
the best things is we just had Shapiro
Ben Shapiro up the other day at one of
our campus he typically gets not only
thousands of kids on campus even on
these liberal campuses but then we live
stream and we put that stuff up on our
YouTube page you have TV and we
literally have millions of people tune
into those things and so that's how we
get around this other nonsense is
finding social media ways to to get
around you know it's the beauty of not
having to go through a limited number of
news sources we can put something up on
Yap TV and other social media sites and
really have an impact that's where we
get right to the students not only in
college high school middle school and
younger what would you say to the high
school kid or I guess to the parents of
the high school kid that that care about
these ideas but they're not ready to not
let the kid go to college or just send
them out into the real world they want
to send them to one of these schools but
then they're just simply looking at the
numbers and they're going man it's now
60 Grand a year to go to I don't know
Syracuse and it's 20 grand a year to go
to a state school like this just does
not work what do you say to those people
well I'd say one increasingly there are
better Alternatives than sending a young
person to a four-year undergraduate
certainly if you want to be an engineer
a doctor a lawyer those are certain
professions where you have to but I
think twice there's a lot of and I wish
I wasn't having to say that but I I
think between the cost the rising costs
which is only going to get worse the the
so-called student debt reduction is only
going to open the door towards more of
these colleges and universities upping
their tuition by 10 grand or more so it
gets offset in that regard but I also
think just the radical indoctrination if
you're going to go though if your kid
your son or daughter grandson or
granddaughter or you as a student are
going to go one of the most important
things whether it's yaf College
Republicans some other conservative
group is surround yourself with as many
like-minded people because you're going
to get exposed to different ideas over
and over again but you want to have a
support network out there the number one
thing we hear at our conference is our
students say oh it's so nice to be
around kids that think the same way we
do and I know with both of my sons who
are 28 and 20 seven now one who went to
a private Jesuit institution which sadly
was woke as well the other went to
University of Wisconsin-Madison which is
left to Berkeley both of them came out
conservatives because of the people they
surrounded themselves with who to this
day are still our allies of theirs I
think that's incredibly important yeah
what do you say to the kids once they
get through it when then they look at
the economy and they go man these jobs
that were being offered we basically we
can't live in big cities because rent is
high and and we do want to get out of
our parents basement but seems like
everybody's going back in there
well again that's part of the reason why
I say reluctantly but sadly that that if
you don't have to be in a a profession
where it requires a four-year
undergraduate degree I'd say find some
other Alternatives a lot of folks
community colleges apprenticeships other
means to get into decent paying jobs
with all that student loan debt on top
of it it's a good reminder again why
socialism communism Marxism might sound
good to some on the surface but it just
doesn't work not only in past history it
doesn't work in Venezuela or Cuba today
it's certainly a problem in Hong Kong
we've seen it not that long on the
Soviet Union but even in big cities you
see so many big cities with the problems
not only with high prices and out of
control rent or housing costs you see it
with cost of living problems you see it
with crime a lot of our large cities
those are all places where you not just
have Democrat or liberal control you
largely have radicals in charge of these
of these governments and I think that's
got to be the constant pushback the
wake-up call if you're concerned about
all these things stop voting for people
people who embraced these ideas because
you're going to get more of it what do
you think we do about the tension
between I think what's growing between
the urban and Suburban communities you
know Lee zeldin obviously did an
incredible job in New York way better
than anyone thought but he did lose and
I looked at the map you know everybody
was showing the map of New York and if
you look at the map of New York it's red
it's almost all red then there's the New
York City metro area and a little bit
sort of towards Buffalo that's pretty
much it but yet they all have to vote
for one governor and I think that
tension is is almost intractable and
it's not New York's not the only place
with that obviously
no you see in variations uh you see it
even in in the New York metro area the
city-wide you look at the difference the
last three gubernatorial works I was
just looking at an interesting map today
about that uh where Manhattan the island
there has gotten deeper and deeper blue
uh you see Staten Island's gotten more
and more red and then you see Pockets
based interestingly enough based on on
Epic Trends you see a lot of folks
fleeing Russia that have come into
Southern or Brooklyn that actually have
made it a little bit more up into
Republicans you see in the Northeast uh
part of of Queens where you see
according to this map it was some of the
increases in Asian population and that's
made it a little bit more open so you
see these divisions out there uh not
only just political but but by groups of
people coming into the country or coming
into a given region we see it though
Nationwide in my state Wisconsin part of
the reason why the governor's race was
not within reach other than the fact
that the Democrat incumbent spent about
twice as much money as the Republic
talking but was Madison where the state
capitol is at and where the university
is at got much higher percentages now we
have total votes but a much higher
margin for Democrats the suburbs were
still Republican but not as much as they
had been in the past and the out state
was a little bit more open to
Republicans but you see this split
between urban areas becoming
increasingly liberal not even just
Suburban Memorial rule to mid-sized
communities becoming strong steady
strongholds I should say for Republicans
there's just a real division in America
we've got to get past that I would one
of the things we talked to students
about is is countering what the left
does over and over again certainly on
campus but even in society if they
disagree with you they call you a series
of names you're you're racist you're
sexist you're transphobic whatever it is
sometimes it doesn't even matter if
that's the topic you're talking about
that's their way of intimidating people
out of real debate real discussion our
counter for those most of his center
right I can't be coming up with their
own series of names but I think rather
pushing this larger nerve that really is
about Unity saying hey I don't care uh
whether you're black or white young or
old rich or poor I don't care what
you're born here you legally came here
for somewhere else I don't care about
your orientation or anything else what I
care about is that you should have the
same freedoms and the same opportunities
as as I inherited and others have
inherited from our parents and
grandparents that's the American dream
that's a bigger issue than just
conservative or liberal out there and
it's the one that truly does bring
people together because then we can
start to see yeah you know the why is
what matters not the what the what will
cause us to have uh political and other
differences but if we believe in the why
the idea that that all of us were
created equal that the government didn't
give us these rights that God gave us
these rights and it's the role of the
the government fundamentally to protect
those rights not the least of which your
life liberty The Pursuit of Happiness if
that we agree on then we can debate the
specifics of the what but right now
sadly most places in this country people
don't even agree on what they think the
why is and that's a big problem if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell